"Get the basketball through
the basketball hoop."
"You may not touch the
basketball with your hands."
"You may not wear gloves
or anything that could
reasonably be construed
to be gloves."
"Fastest wins.
Your time starts now."
Okay.
I see.
Could it be something else
that, like, if I take t--
Okay, well, [bleep] it.
I'm doing it.
Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You mainly wanted them to place
an object through a hoop,
but you didn't want them
to use their hands.
That's the thing.
It's like it's so easy,
and you see people
doing it all the time,
using hands.
And I figured,
"You're a creative lot,
and certainly, there
must be a workaround."
I'm gonna show you
how two of these guys,
each end of the row --
Dillon and Ron, first of all.
-Hi, Dillon.
-Hey.
Let's see.
No hands. Let's try it.
Yep. Nope.
Not enough strength.
Okay.
Let me go to my shed.
♪♪
[ Objects clattering ]
Okay.
I'm ready to play basketball.
Oh, there.
And you plop it in.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Humming ]
Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
Piece of shit.
Ohh!
Lots of strength!
Mm.
Here we go. Right here.
Grandma shot.
[Bleep] Damn it!
You okay?
That was so close.
Okay, I'm back.
With a flower pot?
With a flower pot.
[ Laughs ]
Here we go.
Daddy's home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
True.
Mm. Mm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very well done with
a lot of passion...
-Yeah.
-...lot of anger.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, a little anger.
You were disappointed
in yourself a few times.
Two times.
How long did he take
to arrive --
He?
Yes, he.
Dillon.
Dillon Francis.
Yes.
Dillon Francis,
the producer and deejay.
Yes, producer and deejay.
Yeah, Dillon took
2 minutes and 11 seconds.
That's pretty quick.
Pretty quick.
Ron.
Uh, methodical.
Yeah, well, I mean,
I pretty much have
the same skill level
at basketball
with my hands
or a flower pot, so...
[ Laughter ]
That explains a lot.
So,
I'm new to this country.
I didn't realize people could
walk that slowly to a shed.
But, uh...
Incredible.
Ron took the same amount
of attempts as Dillon,
but he took
a little bit longer.
He took 8 minutes.
Under an hour.
8 minutes.
-All right! That's not bad!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you have any more videos
of other people
performing that task?
I've got two more. The perfect
couple, Lisa and Freddie.
-Ah. Lisa and Freddie.
-Aww!
Maybe could use it
as a football, you know?
[ Audience shouts ]
These aren't gloves.
♪♪
Oh, oh.
What do I do?
Do I have to go in there
and get it?
But I don't want to get wet.
Alex:
You've got a shed.
What's that?
Aah!
Okay.
Hold on.
I forget where the shed is.
♪♪
Oh, dear.
You'll cut out all of
the bad attempts, won't you?
Oh, yeah.
Come on.
Come on!
Oh.
Come on! Go!
Aaaahh!
Suck my [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Aah!
Okay.
♪♪
Yes!
I freakin' rule
this game, bitch.
-Thank you, Lisa.
-Hate that guy.